Salut, c'est dimanche. Je suis toujours malade, j'ai toujours mon écharpe et toi ça va?
moi ça va. Salut.
Aujourd'hui je vais faire une vidéo qui ressemble à
un placement de produit mais c'est pas un placement de produit
parce que je n'ai aucun partenariat avec la marque, que je ne touche pas d'argent et qu'en plus
le produit n'existe plus potentiellement.
Mais c'est extrêmement intéressant,
il y a quelques mois j'avais été contacté par
Kanjivor
qui était une application qui avait lancé
un kickstarter qui s'est terminé
le 5 novembre c'était avant la fin
du kickstarter
j'ai pas eu le temps de faire la vidéo avant
je voulais la faire avant j'ai zappé.
Quoi j'ai zappé, j'ai pas eu le temps
*Générique*
En fait, depuis 2 ans les personnes développaient une application qui permet d'apprendre les... 2136, je crois,
kanji japonais.
Les kanji japonais officiels
en moins de 11 mois
Comme l'application n'existe pas à ce jour
Je ne sais pas d'ailleurs si elle va l'être un jour ou pas, j'ai un prototype papier.
Que je n'ai pas encore essayé et que je vais essayé avec vous
puisque leur concept c'est de faire de l'association d'idée
et ça, vous le savez ça me parle bien.
Donc je vais essayer de faire ça devant vous
pour voir comment ça fonctionne et voir si ça fonctionne bien ou pas
et je vous dirai sincèrement ce que j'en pense
et je vous mettrai dans la description aussi le lien vers le site internet
je vous le dis la campagne Kickstarter c'est terminé
Je ne sais pas si le projet va se développer ou pas
Mais je pense que si vous êtes assez nombreux à vous intéresser et envoyer un mail
peut être qu'ils mettront au point un petit PDF
qu'ils pourront mettre à disposition ou pas.
J'en sais rien
Je ne veux pas parler à leur place.
ils ne sont même pas au courant que je fais la vidéo
Mais je crois que ce genre de chose, de concept en tout cas
d'utiliser les autres circuits de la mémoire
ou plutôt les vrais méthodes de mémorisation.
ça s'est le futur de l'apprentissage
et je suis ravi de voir qu'il y a des applis qui font ça.
Alors par Kanjivor prototype
Niveau 1: Apprendre
olala dis donc ça fonctionne très bien
Mode facile
catégorie de 1 à 100
apprendre de 1 à 10
Vous allez apprendre les Kanji de 1 à 10
Commencer
Regardez chaque flash card,
Ah d'accord c'est basé sur les flashcard, OK
Regardez...
Je vais me mettre comme ça, peut être, on verra mieux
[li l'énoncé] Regardez chaque flashcard pendant un durée de 9 secondes,
vous allez les revoir donc passez à la suivante dés que vous en avez saisi le sens.
OK
D'accord, donc en fait ça fonctionne comme des flashcard
Ah c'est très malin
donc ici on a un... petit garçon avec une casquette
et en fait le Kanji associait, ils sont partis du Kanji pour essayer de trouver une image en rapport
et donc je suppose que ça veut dire petit garçon ou enfant
Enfant. Cet enfant souriant
OK, donc... d'accord
La casquette, toc toc ça s'est enfant
et bien je passe à la suivante
Manabu.
Le travail qu'ils ont fait et vraiment intéressant puisque là
on récupère le Kanji qu'on vient de voir : Ko
et autour ils ont fait une école
et comme on le récupère ici ça veut dire : Apprendre
Celui là il fallait aller le chercher, mais quand même on a les jambes qui se croisent
et la robe...
ça je peux le retenir
d'accord: Femme
on a la femme qu'on récupère là avec le garçon, et ça s'est: Suki
et ça veut dire aime/apprécie
d'accord c'est le double sens
aime et apprécie: Suki. D'accord
Là c'est un arbre
OK, enfin non c'est le bois
Ah si bois ou arbre
et là on dirait un sapin avec un deuxième sapin à côté
Hayashi.
Ce petit bois est en fait un bosquet
d'accord bois/ bosquet en fait c'est un regroupement d'arbres
Voilà, c'est la forêt ça?
oui c'est la forêt 3 sapins
OK, 3 sapins c'est la forêt,
Bois, ah oui donc petit bois ou petite forêt avant quoi
Ça c'est le soleil, ah oui d'accord
là je ne vois pas trop le rapport
cher équipe de Kanjivor, si un jour vous regardez la vidéo mais
Moi j'aurai plus fait une fenêtre où l'on voit un lever de soleil
ça m'aurait plus parler en fait, que le soleil
donc du coup dans ma tête je vais transformer ça en lever de soleil
Et ça c'est la nuit... Aaah
ouais là c'est pareil je vois pas tout à fait bien le rapport
moi là j'aurai imaginé les...
les rideaux qui sont en train de tomber avec un voile et on voyait la nuit derrière
Alors ça, on a presque le jour et la nuit c'est quoi?
Claire/brillante
D'accord quand on a les 2 indices de luminosité c'est clair ou brillante
[Li nouvel énoncé]
Fermez les yeux et respirez profondément durant 10 secondes environ
C'est bien parce qu'il y a tout les circuits de respiration, de relaxation, je trouve ça intéressant pour se re-concentrer
Alors là forcément c'est très très frais donc on s'en souviens bien
Ça aurait été bien de les avoir dans le désordre ou mélangeait ou au milieu de certains qu'on connait pas
là c'est garçon, là c'est la femme,  là c'est le garçon avec la femme donc c'est aimer/apprécier
et ici on a pleins d'arbres donc c'est la forêt, là c'est le bois/bosquet
Là le bois, tout court, enfin l'arbre
Le jour, la nuit. Moi je préfère mes images, je maintiens ça
la clarté/la brillance
Mais oui c'est très bien, je suis persuadé que c'est très efficace
avec une dose d'apprentissage quotidien et tout
c'est vraiment cool
De toute manière, au global, cette vidéo elle est intéressante
parce que ça montre que avec la visualisation et l'association d'images
c'est vraiment ce qu'il y a de mieux à faire pour apprendre les Kanji
Je vous fais voir, quand même, le Kanjivor
alors ne vous fiez plus à ça malheureusement
la campagne est terminée
Ils ont pas obtenu les fonds
Et c'est aussi parce qu'ils n'ont pas retenu les fonds que je trouve ça encore plus important
de parler parler aujourd'hui
Je ne sais pas si le projet va continuer ou pas
Mais, il y a des prototypes qui existent, il y a des choses qui existent
Si ça vous intéresse d'apprendre les Kanji japonais
en 11 mois.
Envoyez leur un petit mail, dites leur que vous avez vu la vidéo ici
Là j'ai pas encore fait l'apprentissage des mots
en même temps, là je les ai retenu parce qu'encore une fois c'est frais
Mais j'ai pas fait l'effort de réellement les retenir
Mais ça. Ça pourrait me motiver à me mettre au Japonais
juste parce que la méthode elle me plait
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
c'était une vidéo un peu différente pour un dimanche
Ben ouais pourquoi pas
C'est aussi fait pour ça le Mental Vlog,
si vous avez aimé ça n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air
La semaine prochaine, on a des trucs un peu de ouf de prévu
Je ne vous le dis pas parce que vous allez vite voir ce que c'est
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir
Et rendez vous demain à 17h.
Bon dimanche
Tchao !